[Music]
hello and welcome my name is Dustin
Kirkland I'm a product manager at Google
cloud and I have the privilege today to
speak with two of my colleagues here
Justin Santa Barbara also an engineer in
Google cloud and we have a guest speaker
a customer of ours twinkle Desai is the
VP of technology at Kohl's and she's
going to introduce the concept of multi
cloud and how that applies to her her
organization I'll hand this to you
twinkle thank you guys for attending
this um so Kohl's is a retailer and a
tech company we love technology we have
huge appetite to invest in technology
and rollout to our customers our goal is
to have a seamless customer experience
my team focuses on building environments
and system to support this ecosystem
which is resilient highly available
highly secure cost-effective and we make
sure that we reach out in the industry
to understand the cutting edge
technology which can bring value to add
to our goals of having that seamless
customer experience as a retailer it's
very critical to make sure we support
the burst traffic during our peak
holiday season which is Black Friday and
Cyber Monday so to ensure that we have a
solution which is not only
cost-effective secured but also low
operational cost we need to make sure
that the system is end-to-end integrated
as a Kohl's we also ensure that we are
not just not a problem solver but also a
forward thinker
so when we talk about multi-cloud
strategy we have to ensure that we meet
our checklist we came up with an
expectation tree it's very important to
know what is a multi-cloud strategy we
want to use and what do we want to
achieve through this our checklist
included the cost effective solution
secured highly available bus traffic
support make sure that it's a
centralized operated solution so that we
don't have to work with multiple
multiple to sets so when we looked at
our various products for us Antos which
is a multi cloud kubernetes seems to be
a perfect fit and that's where we
started working on collaborating our
multi cloud strategy where we are
running multiple payloads in different
cloud solution we have hundred plus
containers and 5000 plus containers
across four stores and digital strategy
running 150 plus micro services we want
to ensure that we still continue to
deliver that seamless customer
experience while having the ability to
support the burst traffic as and when
needed
so and AHS was the right solution for us
and currently we are working to
integrate the entire payload for digital
and stores on this ecosystem I will
invite back Dustin to deep dive into
this product and help us understand
further more thank you
Thank You twinkle I think the
presentation that twinkle gave here
really actually gives us a good starting
point and a concrete set of examples
where multi-cloud and having a multi
cloud strategy is essential to business
continuity and success and what what it
takes to transform a business that's
been around for a long time to really
operate and operate well and efficiently
in a truly new era and so here I have to
speak with you about a handful of
strategies that we we think we can we
can actually help help with and I'll
start here this is something that I hear
from every single customer that I talked
to in 2019 a little bit last year last
year was there was a lot about hybrid
hybrid cloud trying to get to a hybrid
cloud point and maybe maybe 10 years
before that it was just about getting to
cloud at all
but today every time I talk to a
technical leader of any kind in any
organization the question really comes
up yeah Google calcloud is great
but how do these solutions fit into a
truly multi cloud or architecture and
you know I think we can look at it and
start here and we can think about hybrid
cloud as the bridge between using a
public cloud and a private cloud but
multi cloud is that in an extra
dimension which means actually working
with multiple public clouds public
clouds that are in many cases
competitive and that's actually
essential to one of the tenants of the
multi cloud architecture in this case
you know last year at Google next Google
took the remarkable step of bringing gke
on-prem into the the enterprise data
center and now we have quite a number of
customers up and running with Google
cloud technology running inside of their
private cloud environments and the
response has been tremendous and that's
just the starting point that's really
just the starting point and I think
we'll get into what that means but
before we go there I want to sort of
double down on twinkle's display of the
the
tree but the decision tree as to why go
multi-cloud and I've sort of boiled
these down into five or six points five
or six bullets every one of which we've
got tremendous experience helping our
customers solving one or more of these
of these problems
so why multi-cloud that that might be on
some people's minds maybe if you're here
already you're interested in and how
Google helps with this but let me just
make sure that we start with the with a
taxonomy with a set of a set of reasons
and motivations to ensure that we're on
the on the same page and I'll start at
the top you know being able to utilize
more capabilities not every cloud has
every feature as every other cloud and
in some cases you're using one cloud for
a particular feature or two and then
another Club for for another now you
could take a least common denominator
approach and ensure our greatest common
denominator approach and ensure that
you're using the greatest common aspects
of each cloud so that you have perfect
Portability and that makes sense for
some workloads there are other workloads
though that you may want to really focus
in on a particular offering maybe you've
got some specialized AI ml work or you
need a very specialized database or
something else okay so being able to
really tap into the unique
characteristics of a cloud might be one
reason why you need to use more than one
cloud because maybe your first cloud
didn't have one one aspect or another
the second is access to more geographies
and there are lots of reasons why you
might need access to another geography
some of the customers I talked to
especially in the in the gaming industry
need need to have their data really
close to the users playing those games
it's a latency it's a it's a laws of
physics problem at that point shaving
down to two milliseconds or microseconds
of of latency is important in the in the
a and the AR VR augmented reality
virtual reality world or some of the
gaming world
but it's not just there it's also in in
banks and FinTech we see data that
cannot move from one geography to
another and all of these are reasons why
a multi cloud approach might actually be
the right answer in some cases it's a
private cloud running and in certain
geographies in other cases it's a matter
of using one or more clouds to
supplement those geographies being able
to ensure that you can run those
workloads in a place where one of the
public clouds doesn't doesn't exist it
doesn't have a presence now the data
gravity problem is also one that we hear
quite a bit about and we see the data
gravity problem across all industries
I'm working with a couple of oil and gas
companies where this is really what it's
all about same with the auto and the
self-driving car industry there's so
much data that is resident in one cloud
or another meanwhile there's other work
that that happens in a different cloud
or on-premise um where else and yet
crunching that data close to that data
is essential to these to these
algorithms even even working and so
having a multi cloud strategy to solve
the the data gravity problem your data
is here but something else needs to
happen somewhere else is another driver
for foregoing multi-cloud reducing
vendor dependency is it comes in a lot
of different shapes and forms in some
cases it's a matter of having the
ability to negotiate on prices buy in
bulk although that goes that goes both
ways sometimes it's better to go all in
on one cloud and get as much as as much
bulk discount as possible in other cases
just having multiple vendors is
something that I think we've learned
over the last couple of decades of
enterprise software and and buying
software as a service sourcing from
multiple vendors certainly gives the
buyer certain certain advantages but
it's not just that it's also reducing
the risk the risk around one vendor
failing are going down spreading a
workload across multiple clouds and load
balancing across that's something that
I've worked with a number of startups
that
grow to a certain certain size and then
become pretty essential to
too-big-to-fail especially in the in the
transportation and the and the the
financial space in which case you see a
disaster recovery or a failover scenario
with a given workload or a database
being replicated across across multiple
clouds it's something that when we get
to the the demo Justin will will touch
on for sure and that resilience to
failure is baked into that so it's it's
for reducing the vendor dependency but
also the dependency on the things that
that aren't human you know the machinery
underneath the network connections the
distributed denial of service attack
that might hit one vendor harder than
another vendor or at different times
perhaps and then the last one is really
just you know as an exercise in large
industry the result of mergers and
acquisitions you you buy a company and
that company comes with its own
dependencies its own preferences for
lots of things maybe it's the brand of
office equipment and chairs and
conference rooms but that that company
also comes with its own preferences
around software as a service and public
cloud are a private cloud as a service
there's a lot of nuance a lot of nuance
in each and every one of these I would
I'd ask if if to please raise your hand
if at least one of these did not strike
a nerve with why you would go
multi-cloud okay I've successfully got
no one to raise their hand that's a
little anticlimactic okay so now we're
gonna move into sort of a second segment
of this talk and this is I'm gonna call
this the chalk talk I actually created
these slides while I was watching March
Madness the NC double-a basketball
tournament and I love basketball I'm
always inspired by a coach that'll you
know take off their jacket and really
get down with the team and and and coach
coach from the coach from the bench okay
so now we're into chalk talk and we're
gonna start with a couple of formulas
we're gonna do this as a math chalk talk
so this isn't a basketball chalk talk
this is a math talk chalk talk maybe I'm
talking more to the tech audience about
math and basketball I don't know I think
I crossed both both of those so the the
formulas start here we're gonna start
from here and build up containers is
something that I don't need to explain
to this crowd anymore four or five years
ago I think we would have had to have a
where did containers come from was
docker first or Solaris zones first but
I think this is all well understood well
understood at this point and when it
comes to multi cloud there's one thing
that containers gives you that's
absolutely essential to everything you
want to do in a multi cloud environment
and that's portability the ability to
move your code your workload your data
from one place to another physical or
virtual or otherwise from on-prem to the
cloud and back and forth from your
developer laptop in the coffee shop
pushing to the build system pushing to
cloud a cloud be cloud see when you when
you fire one vendor and you buy another
vendor being able to move that and
containers are at the heart of that and
yes virtual machines have always been
able to sort of move between clouds but
it's it's really containers that that
got the the concept and boiled it down
to its simplest and most critical
definition which is an application some
code that you bought that you bought or
you wrote that bundles its dependencies
and everything it needs to run and
because it's in that atomic unit as an
image it can now move it can now move
anywhere and it was containers and
docker containers that really
democratize that technology and put that
into the hands of everyone there are a
lot of companies that were doing
container a container like things for
decades
but this this really this this tectonic
shift in the landscape happened four or
five years ago about about twenty
fourteen now once you have a lot of
containers like containers to the
containers power right you've now got a
problem you've got a lot more machines
to
manage than you ever had in the physical
world more things to configure than you
ever had in the virtual world it's
really an exponential truly an
exponential problem and it's kubernetes
that happened about that same time four
or five years ago that actually provided
proper tooling to be able to handle that
exponentially more complex scale and
scope that containers introduced into
your into your enterprise I certainly
spoken with a number of executives who
now look back on that moment when they
realized they had this problems of
sprawl sprawl of code maybe there were
licensing issues or support issues or
otherwise and now being able to manage
that from a single place where
kubernetes sort of came in and helped
with a lot of that now I think you know
kubernetes is built on decades of
experience at Google managing up teen
millions of containers over the years on
borg as jobs as persistent services and
and we've made that available made that
available to the open-source community
in the CNC F the cloud native computing
foundation but certainly as a product
from Google as well and that's the
google kubernetes engine now as I
alluded to earlier last year's we
tackled the hybrid cloud problem we
brought gke google kubernetes engine
which we all we've run as a hosted
service managed service inside of Google
Cloud we ported that to run inside of
the private data center anywhere that
you have a vSphere with the appropriate
number of physical and virtual machines
we can stand up a google kubernetes
engine on Prem gke on Prem inside of
that enterprise data center and we're
working on extending that we're working
on bringing that to other other
environments as well beyond the our
starting point which we've we've
established and it's working really well
but now we're starting to gather that
feedback
those those initial customers as to
where else they want to take google
kubernetes and use that and use that
elsewhere so now you've got a bunch of
kubernetes a bunch of clusters and
inside of that you've successfully
deployed X to the Y containers and
you're scheduling and scaling them up
and down and that's great so you've
actually gone multi cloud at this point
but by this point in the talk if you
followed and implemented that you've now
got you've now got kubernetes running in
multiple places and and manage that
congratulations and you've deployed a
bunch of services into that you haven't
done that just for the exercise of doing
that you've actually deployed work into
each and every one of those and once
you've done that you now have services
that need to talk to other services you
have humans that maybe need to talk to
some of those services but you probably
have a lot of machines and other
services that need to talk to other
services and that's ultimately the
problem that sto solves sto as part of
the kubernetes family it's another open
source project started at Google that
ensures that services can talk to other
services and do so securely it's called
a service mesh and it handles a lot of
the complexity around generating
certificates and the certificate
management the securing of services in
both directions from one to another and
this is a big problem without something
like Sto distributing certificates and
in ensuring that route of trust from one
service to another is that problem
spaces ripe with a lot of different
solutions many of which are brittle and
or homegrown or just weren't really
designed for the cloud native nature of
containers but sto was and that's that's
exactly what we hear from customers
saying that every day they're using to
reduce the complexity of communication
between those services so sto is often
used in conjunction with another project
another open-source project called envoy
an envoy handles the spreading of
network across a bunch of services both
inbound from a from a proxy and and low
balancing perspective
and it well it's really about the
inbound at this point so being able to
to handle service those micro services
and the traffic going to those micro
services and route that traffic
appropriately using load balancers and
tied into now there's a lot of different
ways that you can and will use load
balancers in your in your clusters and
in your kubernetes envoy is one of them
and it's it's natively part of this this
sort of ecosystem and you know these
these are quite useful in handling that
that traffic now server lessor functions
as a service is another another
methodology that's often employed in in
multi cloud and Kay native is another
project that we've implemented on top of
kubernetes so we use kubernetes as a
base and then we've implement a service
engine called Kay native that sits on
top of kubernetes and it can sit
anywhere kubernetes runs and what's
important here is that you know many of
the server less engines are or feel
certainly like a vendor lock-in it's
it's something that's native to that
cloud and it's something that you want
to use and you need to use but if you're
still staying true to that multi cloud
strategy you might be caught in a bit of
a bind but Kay native is how you can
actually how you can actually continue
to use of functions as a service or a
service engine and avoid that vendor
that vendor lock-in this is important to
staying true to that that that that
multi cloud strategy now part and parcel
to every single a containerized
environment especially in the multi
cloud is a good CI CD system continuous
integration continuous development
ensuring that your developers can write
some code build that code test that and
deploy that across multiple clouds I
mean you've just blown out your matrix
right now that you have to be able to
run that same code anywhere you need to
ensure that you can test that same code
anywhere generally containers will
handle the portability and it'll ensure
that you can move your code from one
place or another
but you need to be able to very quickly
detect where someone somewhere has baked
and an unexpected dependency on
something that may not exist somewhere
else at some point and that's where
something like cloud build or any of the
any of a number of of CI CD continuous
integration continuous development
platforms on top of kubernetes can help
with that and it's all baked very nicely
in the kubernetes which handles the
scheduling of the new container that
builds your code and maybe runs your
code and then spits out that that tests
those test results into a comprehensive
comprehensive view and speaking of view
it's hard to talk about multiple clouds
without at least thinking about what a
single pane of glass might look like so
ensuring that you have a single pane of
glass across multiple estates perhaps on
Prem in one cloud cloud to cloud three
and in your own and your own private
clouds is also something that we hear
all the time is just fundamental to
implementing a multi cloud strategy and
so we have that it's a it's called the
Google Cloud console and from that
Google Cloud console which justin will
certainly show you from that single
Google Cloud console you can see
multiple clusters you can access those
clusters you can deploy workloads and
destroy workloads and scale those
workloads all from a single single UI
and it's a graphical user interface but
they're good command-line tools and
api's certainly for every one of those
it's just one of our sort of guiding
principles and this all works because
that cloud console aggregates all of the
information about your clusters into a
hub we call that the we call that the
the gke hub and it's because inside of
every cluster there's an agent that
authenticates with your account and
communicates with that hub and provides
the information the control information
the metadata information about that
cluster so that the the console can
render that for you it also catches
receives the messages that that you post
there
asking that clustered to do something so
it's a it's bi-directional it's
bi-directional communication and you're
able to do that with your you know with
a single unified view across your entire
estate anywhere anywhere in the world
and one of the things that I think we
see more than anything more used than
anything else inside of that single pane
of glass is the log aggregation the
monitoring of all of the clusters
anywhere we provide some some really
first-class monitoring and logging
solutions in Google cloud with
stackdriver
and we integrate with a number of others
you can certainly run your own ELQ stack
cabana elastic and you can run your own
Prometheus org or fauna and many of
those run natively all of those run
natively as containers inside a
kubernetes so once you have a kubernetes
you can deploy those as workloads inside
and then use those to monitor and so
being able to do that with any cluster
anywhere aggregate that and and process
those logs trigger on failure learn from
those logs and train your models so that
you've got you know predictive ways of
avoiding problems in the in in the
future
but doing that across multiple clouds is
it's quite it's quite remarkable and
that's something that that will we'll
see here in just a second and then you
know managing those clouds and
especially the configure those clusters
managing the configuration across those
clusters being able to to
comprehensively push out a security
policy across many systems and and
combine those into into new and
interesting and secure ways is essential
and and just really part of ensuring
that you've got a multi cloud story that
is secure and that you're able to roll
out an update to that policy everywhere
so config management is also part of
this platform that I'm describing and I
will I'll leave this last one before we
sort of bring this all together we've
also got something called the gke
marketplace and it's a marketplace of
solution software so
oceans containers ultimately that can
run originally in your gke clusters the
clusters that the clusters that you run
inside a Google cloud that marketplace
and all those solutions and that's a
factorial not an exclamation point all
of those solutions there come together
and you can deploy those they're
open-source third-party solutions
there's commercial software there's
Google provided software in that
marketplace you can deploy those in new
and interesting ways on Prem in Google
Cloud and now in in other clouds and
this is all of these together the sum
total is ultimately the thing that
hopefully you heard about this morning
which we're calling anthos and those
being a new platform it's truly a
platform that crosses hybrid and and
multi cloud this is how you actually
solve the hybrid and multi cloud problem
modernizing your applications as
containers enforcing the security around
the policy and doing so at scale
on-premises in our cloud and in other
clouds that's what we've set out to
build here graphically it looks
something like this
I touched on a lot of these hexagons
over the course of the our little math
tutorial here but this is how we're
seeing this ecosystem evolved this is
the combination of services necessary to
bring together a platform that that
moves from one place to another and has
that that persistent experience and with
that you know I think I'll I'll leave us
with just sort of a thought that the the
ethos of anthos is that it's a it's a
common language across any any cloud
it's how things move from one place to
another and in that way it's it's a lot
like math math is a common language no
matter where you're from it's constant
it it it's consistent it's something
that we can all relate to we don't get
to change it it's not it's not something
that we get to have opinions about
there's there
facts and that's what we've set out to
build a common language that operates
across across clouds and so at this
point as in any good Google Talk we're
going to have a live demo that my
colleague Justin here will will lead you
want this sure thank you Thank You
Justin that was great all right I'm
gonna try to show you in this demo sort
of how we put those formally into
practice you could say I'm going to sort
of plug some numbers into the equations
that Dustin presented quick outline of
what we're gonna do because we're going
to go through pretty fast to me I should
get to it we're gonna show how
containers and kubernetes give us
portability across clouds we're gonna
hit a bunch of different kubernetes
clusters in different clouds we're going
to look at that single pane of glass the
cloud console so we can sort of get
visibility into our workloads and our
clusters wherever they are we're gonna
show how sto gives us the ability to
understand what's happening in terms of
services and also gives us connectivity
across those different clusters we're
going to look at logging and tracing
information across those clusters again
through stackdriver we're gonna show
configuration management we're gonna use
that to do what I hope is a pretty cool
move which hopefully wake you all up a
little bit and then we're gonna dig into
like how you can pick services from
around the web focusing on bigquery
which is a good service that Google
offers and also then the marketplace
which is a way to get services that
other people may offer and with that
let's construct our example here so we
are in our scenario here we are going to
do I might have to debug Linux display
on the fly which is always challenging
hold with me for just one second
Mirror apologies no applause not even
for that I should say a lot of these
things that were showing thank you
although these things are showing this
week are very new so if this does all
work then definitely that doesn't warn
around of applause in our
our example we're gonna pretend that we
are an e-commerce retailer and we have a
fairly traditional multi-tier app we
have a web front-end which serves our
web and mobile app users we have a
product catalog component which stores
the descriptions of the products that
we're selling we have an ERP system that
runs on a mainframe that really powers
our business and although we've put an
ERP gateway in front of that mainframe
that really keeps everything on Prem
right now but the web front-end
communicates with the catalog to serve
browsing traffic and with the ERP system
for the actual orders we have started
everything is running on Prem because of
that your P system on the mainframe but
everything's we have started to adopt
kubernetes in the data center and we've
been using GK on Prem which is great
because it will make this a lot easier
going forwards and we were starting to
run our workloads in portable containers
now this isn't really what people would
consider multi cloud yet of course but
that data warehouse is actually running
in the cloud we are we can run bigquery
for example and tie into cloud ml and ai
functionality and so already in this
example we have some multi cloud we're
already choosing the best capabilities
wherever they're located so I suspect
that actually if we go out there most of
you are already doing multi cloud to an
extent today and similarly if you think
about how you do DevOps today you're
probably doing that not all in one data
center where you run your workloads you
probably have that spread out and across
multiple locations how we were doing
DevOps here well let's get to some code
right so here we have the code that
powers this demo app it's in a get
repository hosted on Google Cloud source
repositories but you might be using
github for example but you can see our
different components we have our
front-end we have our catalog service we
have our ERP with the ERP gateway there
and whenever I push a build on a wrapper
to let we trigger a build here for our
CI CD system we're using cloud build and
you can see I have a trigger and so
whenever I push a build fires off in the
cloud which is great in terms of burst
ability and you can look at some of my
previous builds so I'm from more
recently and I care to admit and when I
dig into it you can see that they
actually this build succeeded and the
output of this was 3
images there's portable container images
which we're gonna run on kubernetes
again and those are actually
automatically pushed into the container
registry here so here you can see I'm
for this container registry for this
example I'm running on Google's
container registry but again you could
run wherever you want note that our
kubernetes cluster is running on Prem
but our container registry is running in
the cloud I think everyone should be
familiar with this but it is it is
something we are able to do and that's
actually pretty impressive and that's
done by containers and kubernetes
alright and whatever offerings you want
GCP obviously has great offerings but
you can mix and match with whatever you
you choose that's sort of the power or
the promise of multi cloud I think
that's pretty good from a developer
perspective we have a fairly nice push
to deploy pipeline going there but let's
talk a little bit about the sort of
operational side the observability which
is sort of the right-hand side of the of
the slide here so let's look at our
kubernetes clusters so you can see here
that in Google Cloud console we have a
bunch of kubernetes clusters that appear
even if they're not running GTA ii so we
have here a GAE cluster which of course
appears we have a gke on-prem cluster
which appears and we have a kubernetes
cluster that isn't Jiki Jiki at all it's
actually running in AWS we built that
using pops because the team is pretty
cool but you know you can use any open
source kubernetes cluster you you want
to so we'll come back to the two cloud
guys in a minute
but let's have a little look at what
we're able to see it on the on-prem
cluster through the cloud console even
though it's running on Prem so you can
see we can like look at our nodes get
basic observability of that but we can
also look at the actual workloads that
are running on Prem and you can see you
see on the right there we have our three
clusters or three three workloads but
they're all running on Prem we have our
front-end our catalog and our ERP
gateway and that's despite the fact that
this is again running on Prem and we're
looking at it through the cloud alright
but let's now see what other information
we can get
let's have a first look at the app so
this is the app running on Prem you can
see the on Prem in the URL there and I
click around my example app which I
invested a lot of time into and we've
generated some traffic so now we can
again stick a switch to stackdriver
where we should now start to see through
kubernetes in sto a lot of the
information that came in from is coming
in from our from our app alright we
don't much as I thought but you can see
for example that are we here is a
request let's see a web request it looks
like that hit the front end and you can
see that it it is the resource is a
kubernetes container and the cluster is
on Prem it's running on Prem and the
other one will presumably be the backend
service that satisfied that let's see
yes the catalog service there we are you
get all the logging type view
stackdriver has some nice views on this
the I think the my favorite view is that
the tracing view so if you want to
really understand what's going on in a
sort of multi tier service let's see a
little might generate little bit more
traffic let's see there we go that
worked alright there so what you can see
here we have a trace view which is a
distributed trace across the various
tiers of our tiers of our application so
we hit the front end there and we hit
the catalog service there and you can
see on the sort of details here that the
cluster is once again on Prem because of
course everything is still running on
brim but despite the fact is running on
Prem again we're looking at all that
information through Google Cloud console
in the cloud service alright so this has
all been sort of multi cloud but mostly
for running the cluster let's move our
data plane let's move our app itself
across multiple clouds we have those
clusters sitting there let's let's use
them we would like to have the choice to
run our website somewhere in the cloud
to better handle spikes as we were told
earlier and to put it in geographies
closer to our customers
we made a great move by putting our app
in kubernetes so it should be relatively
easy and we're everything to the cloud
except for that mainframe dependency
which is sort of keeping us on Prem so
we're going to have to figure something
out and kubernetes in ISTE oh now to the
rescue so we are going this is our
current scenario everything is running
on Prem and we want to do this slightly
difficult trick which is to split our
application across with the front-end
running in the clouds in two different
clouds in fact and tunneling that
traffic back to the on Prem cluster this
this is a kubernetes environment so you
could just use coop cuddle to do this
but you notice and I actually drew a box
at the top for configuration management
with a big arrow and that is this is
what configuration management makes easy
and lets you do declaratively so i'm
gonna show you just how easy that really
is we have a code source repo again
another git repo again in cloud source
repositories but it could be anywhere
and you can see we have our clusters
described in here and we have a couple
of selectors this is configuration
management we have a couple of selectors
here that for example the on-prem
selector says only in what the on-prem
environment where is the selector all
says the the environment can either be
on Prem or cloud and you can see we have
again we have our three tiers front-end
catalog and ERP described right here
okay I will first show that there is
nothing up my sleeves actually don't
have sleeves today but there we are so
we have we have an AWS URL which is
obviously not working and a gke sorry
did not mean that we have our our cloud
ones which are not yet working I will
now edit the policy to deploy let's see
so there are a selector on Prem and all
we have to do to move this front-end the
front-end kubernetes applications - on -
from on Prem to all our all our clusters
is to basically change the selector
we're going to change it from select
around Prem - selector all
we will save we will get add so there in
case you missed it they're changing from
selector on pram to selector all we do a
git commit deploy front end to all
clouds push we are pushing okay and now
if I'm fast enough that workloads of you
that we had before let's see yes I beat
it okay we should shortly see that was
not a challenge to be this we should
shortly see the front end deploying
there we go so you can see that the
front end is now deploying to these two
additional clouds AWS and gke of course
it's already running an on-prem if i
refresh you will see that of course it's
it's good all right if we hit this it's
still not going to work but we're gonna
we're gonna get closer so you can see
that we have some errors about upstream
connect errors if you know GRP see this
is about cross service connectivity and
the reason is that we haven't actually
made the cloud clusters able to connect
back to our on prem system this is where
is teo comes in so we just need to
change the the end point for our catalog
service sto is able to do multi cluster
routing and we change it from the
kubernetes internal name to the name we
gave the multi cluster service we change
it use multi cluster service let's push
that and again we should see if I'm fast
enough we should see it starts to deploy
again or roll out the new configuration
we might miss this but let's just go
yeah let's watch it so it goes it is
rolling out on a device first it looks
like there they go it's rolling across
all three clusters and just wait one
more time looks like we should be close
enough alright we are now running on AWS
and we have our website running it is
going
/ Sto back to our on-prem cluster
talking to our erp gateway talking to
our mainframe and we can click around as
before
and of course we can also run it on gke
and there we go and even more magically
of course our logging still works
although now we're able to see if we
click down and get lucky that we are
running in that's still on Prem we are
running in multiple clusters okay I
won't keep guessing let's look at the
trace for you the Traci was much easier
to understand so here we are so let's
look at this one which took a while
let's find a good one there we go so
here we are so here we have one that
started off in the AWS cluster for this
top one and then the catalog service was
running in on print so we managed to
cross that so I think that's pretty cool
all right and I will close us out with a
quick look at the other pieces so the
idea of sort of business metrics
bigquery is a great solution for for
business metrics that we're streaming
our sales pretty much live into bigquery
right now and if I do this a couple of
times you can see if you look very
carefully that the timestamps should be
changing there they are they are
changing and of course because it's
bigquery you can then build a fancy
dashboard maybe and I can refresh and
the order count should go from 3 the
order count went up so this is indeed
live data that's that's yes exactly when
you make it up you can make good money
and you know bigquery is of course a
great great system but if if you wanted
to look at other solutions from other
vendors if for example you wanted to get
your your CRM data going into bigquery
for example there's a marketplace
solution for that you can install it
just like that and maybe you have a like
a pricing engine that runs on spark and
so in the marketplace there's a spark
carburetor ready to go we can choose to
configure it
we can choose to deploy it and of course
we can deploy it onto our gke cluster of
course we can deploy it onto our GK on
Prem cluster but we can also deploy it
onto our kubernetes cluster that is
running on another cloud on AWS so you
just hit deploy and it's that easy
so that is a very quick outline of
containers giving portability across
clouds kubernetes the single pane of
glass the console being able to see
everything everywhere
sto being able to power the multi
cluster traffic stack driver to give us
a view across all those clusters a
configuration management so that we were
able to deploy workloads moving from
just one cluster running on Prem to
multiple clusters perhaps even more
easily than running a single cluster
bigquery for business metrics and the
marketplace to deploy solutions onto any
cluster anywhere
[Music]